こんにちははじめ社長です本日はご覧
くださいこちらのスタジオとても豪華な
セットを準備していただいたんですけれど
も今回ですねヒカキンさんと僕でおさつ
どきってお菓子があるんですけどもその
おさつどきの cm の撮影に今回来て
おりますおさつどき知っていますか35年
以上の歴史のある昔で今回その縮むに
ヒカキンさんと私が出るんですけども
ただし生むとる訳じゃありませんこちら
ご覧くださいお願いします
みなさんこれを見て何かわかります
でしょうか人が落ちた時の衝撃を吸収する
ウレタンキューブなんですけどもつない
う形だけこの上でヒカキンさん土木が
ceo の撮影するんですけども以上発令
あの日か計算に cm を撮影してたら
突然落とし穴りをチロッ経営
怒られないか心配ですこの上で基本的に
日影さんと cm とるんですけども僕が
あっ違うです僕のところは何もないんです
けどヒカキンさんだけ落とし味になって
ます多分日か妓生落とし穴にハマったこと
がないのであの伝説のユーチューバー
ヒカキン竿を通し穴に居るのは俺しかい
ないきっかり実際に僕が落ちてみます突然
やるの比較インターにしてるのでは
[音楽]
これはわかってるとマジでやばいな
ちょっと
[音楽]
5年以下ゲートそうといきます
ルー
はあああああrarかっこいいっ
体を仕掛けます多分ヒカキンさんを僕の
経験とすごい注意深い方なんですよ
ドッキリする時かなり注意深い方なので涌
波さんの社長さんも及び地で本当に cm
撮影してますという空間をつくって最後の
最後に落とすので課金さんが厚る最高の姿
ぜひお試しくださいで愛子
あよろしくお願います
なくてない何回もの頃ず飲めちゃうなんか
の方ってくって言わないと思いましてね
音が鳴ります宜しくしますよろしくお願い
します今年の一押しの商品ですので
ものすごくもの沿っ電車に期待しますんで
やっぱり野菜の詰め合わせ
はいあーんもちろんを刺す時も入ってます
よねあってあげます
それで始めはですね最も尊くれるんです
けど
202 j してますかー
voodoo はぁっはぁっはぁっはい
よろしいもの構成になっておりますはい
よろしくお願いしますここはねはい
だんだん鉄鋼あとはねこれ8姉ちゃんるが
ブサです
ネット c 分
このこっちゃそうですあとはみきみたいな
感じ
[音楽]
4したい一番最初はカメラがあれを見る
買う者です別目カメラはねこの辺について
いきますので手がベタベタにならないのが
嬉しいなぁ
電ケそうですね
勝ったことに超一監督の方に確認を
いただいてはい
ok が出れば
助けた一やさしいになる
今日はおりですよいい
心配だと思い
皆さんこのおやつ知ってますかもちろん
知ってますよねお札度聞いてもテロを知っ
てますよね菩薩時一手が渡り建屋は足り
ないもっともらおう
あっ走ってるかも高いと思うと思いねーよ
ペアボウル
特約の根源頭たじゃあでも本当にたはいと
結構にいればなずっとコースターと方は
ちょっと苦手なジャンプちょいあった
lanvin 選手なんですね今後の参考
に
ん
って言ってた学んでいてもいいですか監督
へ杉崎はよろしくねっ
1さんらしくですデフ軽い感じで合わせ
なきゃやっぱりね
おさつどきはえんそくのおやつに必ず持っ
てってたわぁああ早く食べますいいいい
感じだと思います
[音楽]
8やいっ
時は36年の前から愛され続けるね
発売当初 cm なんかすげー手が
ベタベタにならないのが嬉しいのよ
所構成がたっぷり入っていて体にも優しい
となる席だけなんですね
同じも墓穴大丈夫と思います
はいありますはいオッケーですよああ
はいっ
発売当初の cm なんかすげー
はいいいんじゃないでしょいい
あのドッキリなんですけどいつもしっくり
と cm を撮影しておりますこれで家
カチッ頭にはないと思うんですよ引き続き
頑張ってきます
おっ
[音楽]
やああいっ
2020年おさつどきは35周年を迎え
ました
素晴らしい実家計算
[拍手]
[音楽]
w いつか
あとパイピングの名称だけしてみましょう
かを実際にはせずに
1回練習だけしてタイミングの名称です
いただきまーす
ばっちりですねはいん
[音楽]
大量のプロが取り組んで
商人伊佐で割りましょう
4位はいっ
いただきます
ああああああっいや
重いやつよ作った
3東京の責任問題ですねが使えないわかり
ます基本とエナジー40 greddy
なんとかタウンません本当に前は転換とき
腰椎から今日くださいはいキュッ
んねおいそげっ
やっぱしません
日本
ためですこれを買った本店ください
やー
はい
いただきわー
ありがとういいんじゃないですか
ゆっツリーですね ok ですねはい
ございません
一発 ok 舌の初めて機能性も大丈夫
っていうの方をちゃんと撮れてなかったん
ですね
cm 流れるよね
ね
楽しみですね流れる
いいんじゃないですよね普通の中も見てみ
て完璧だったんですはい
これで
シャーレてマッハ
今後とも宜しくおねマス
て食べましたですございましたそれじゃ
さーんこのした話だとかありますあったば
ヒカキンさんに走ったこの c 3決めて
いただいて最高のさっきから歳かぁいい
待ってはさりながらいうほしいそうなん
ですよ ok です
いや結構一瞬マジなはぎのバストピース
くださいわけかのシーンをつきましたと
いう
ません
ええええええ
お願いしまーす
家顔だありがとう
goo
何かあってきだすフックもうちょっとピン
としていません
[音楽]
はいっ
うーん愛甲
よく
死亡しますけどその日限り雑魚難いぷる
もう何パターンがもらってもいいですか
最高の笑顔バージョンもらってもいいです
か最高多いたいなうーん
あれ剤ねしまーすん
はいん
yeahファイバー
もう俺はもう max 場合ですかね
ですよそれでも最後あのいつでもいまの
ところいいの撮れてるんですけどちょっと
ペンション有馬ぐらいの位置が
はテンション max でお願いします
じゃあ
決めてください分はいやー
はい
ん
うーん
最後わー
最後は最初はわー
サイバー
バッハ
ああああああ
バッハあああああっはぁ
ていますあああああっはぁ
はぁ
バッハ2
通常らーんよえっ
うーんをつけたんでしたっ
この規模はダメはろーっということで
su 作詞てたらしか芸座落とし穴どっ型
でしたーー
[音楽]
ブーバーし始めて落ちたねブー
ブーってほとんどマネージャーロスあんて
な2本トッキーニョちわぁ
視聴忘れないよ
よねある蔵書
いつかなんかししかしして約4
相手いうわけで今回ですね大やっぱさせて
頂いたこちらのお札ドキンなんですけども
全国のスーパーやコンビニなどで購入でき
ますのでぜひ食べてみてください
おいしかったですかおいしかったんです
けどこっちもねーだろうなマジで美味しい
ので一気にさほどないぜ3でぜひ食べてみ
てくださいうぇい
わー
あっは
[音楽]
blr